you think you're smarter than him
you think you're gonna be the one that's
gonna get him to confess well i don't
think i'm smarter
sir i don't think you necessarily have
to be smarter
this is what's gonna happen he will come
down
he'll toy with you for a little while
does your son know what you do
he knows his daddy protects people he
will cat and mouse with you he will make
you think you are getting somewhere
press record and let's get this party
started
it is february 13th 1986.
this is agent bill hagmaier i'm sitting
with theodore ted
i'm sitting with ted bundy ted bundy has
13 hours to live
and he is using those hours to try and
buy himself more time
he's ready to talk he said he's ready to
confess to everything but only talk to
one person
there are families out there looking for
answers the world needs to know why he
killed those girls
you're some hot shot young upstart and
i'm your next big case you're gonna be
the guy who broke me
there are a lot of myths and
misunderstandings about me
what are you going to tell me everything
what do you think you want you and i
will sit down and have the conversation
you've wanted this whole time
when you get too close to a guy like
this you can lose your way
do you think you could kill somebody i'm
an fbi agent
that's not what i'm saying you can't
hold these girls hostage
i'm not playing games how many did you
kill let's say 30. let's say we talk
about the real number 30 is a nice
random
you're getting inside my head i'm
looking for understanding
you think they should kill me don't you
you think it's my time to die frankly
they probably should have done it a long
time ago
i'm going to take you somewhere that
i've
never taken anyone before
i need a moment with bill he's my best
friend
[Music]